oui
je suis la tension semaine
[Musique]
votre femme a perdu le contrôle de son
véhicule comme si elle s'est endormie au
volant
c'est fréquent revanche ce qui l'est
beaucoup moins c'est ce que l'autopsié a
révélé et je voulais vous présenter
toutes nos condoléances
j'imagine très bien ce que ça peut être
tu m'avais que pour moi
une soleil
le ti cul
[Musique]
il n'y aura pas comme ça je suis perdu
rien
je suppose qu'elle m'a imaginer de mort
violente accident de voiture il faisait
quoi tu reçois mon élément
j'ai essayé des repêchés
et si vous décidez de tout vous raconter
ce que vous savez
serait pas bien fermé la pac au tibet
[ __ ] de gueule mais demandez
simplement je ne voulais pas me donner
cordes je me suis remis un message peut
être assurée windstein sur nos
informations confidentielles vous
contenu
[Musique]
de l'epr de quelque chose nancy mais
j'ai peur que la cicatrice au plus
douloureuse que la plaie
[Musique]